hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Alan sockin we have the great
great pleasure of sitting down with
George Gilder now thank you
well it's great to be here Alan thank
you for having me here and this
inconvenient time it's super convenient
but we'll have some convenient truth
expounded during the course of it yes we
will and we're here at KO fest Institute
very grateful to be partnered up with
them Congress on the future of
engineering software George gave a talk
earlier today we're very fortunate to
have him speaking here so George for
those that don't know is a venture
capitalist
he is a 20 time author crazy
it'll take me months to read all those
books and they're really incredibly
known and sourced books actually and
we're going to get into some of them as
we discuss and also the co-founder of
the Discovery Institute which is anti
junk science and celebration of
enterprise and creativity so I'm already
just by reading the article of your
conversation on Forbes I mean we already
are vibing on a lot of the same
wavelength oh good well rich Karl Gard
is a great interviewer he was yeah he
brought me to Forbes I brought him to
Forbes we both did ASAP which was the
Forbes technology magazine for 6-7 years
I can't remember how long we ran it but
it was a terrific run we had with Forbes
ASAP
yeah which became my articles which were
in each issue became Telecom which was a
major book that came out unfortunately
in the year 2000 when the market crashed
but but telecom still is alive and
brings me a flow of royalties so
somebody's reading it and George's
George also ran do run of 5k today or
did you run 10 K today I ran tank I ran
to 5 km one in the morning I've got a I
got to be on a plane all dated all night
tonight so I
thought if I ran a 5k tonight but I ran
the 5k in 28 minutes which is reasonable
for a 78 year old fart like me Wow
that's under ten minute miles that and
then wow nine eleven miles those words
that's fantastic very few good people
kids today that tape can do that well
excellent that's in this gonna keep you
in great health and we need you around
longer to be talking about the things
that you're talking about so maybe we
start off by talking about information
theory you know teach us about this well
information that is critical to
capitalism my my assertion is that
capitalism is not chiefly an incentive
system everybody wants to talk about
carrots and sticks and incentives and
capitalism that that is not the heart of
capitalism it sentencer ubiquitous
everybody has a pattern of incentives
but capitalism is chiefly an information
system and information under information
theory is developed by Claude Shannon
chiefly but with lots of precursors and
followers like gregory chaitin and
others shows that information is
surprise and we compare this to the Rube
Goldberg machine Rube got what what
about the Rube Goldberg machine because
I just love that I know what a rowboat
Goldberg machine is of crazy contraption
with all kinds of bizarre connections
and and government is mainly a Rube
Goldberg machine and that is that that
surprise or that innovation or that
creativity comes from these Rube
Goldberg moments I know I don't think a
Rube Goldberg is is a joke machine you
know a Rube Goldberg machine is bizarre
Cluj as they call it with all kinds of
crazy wheels and cogs and connections
that that are weird right so it's not
quite a Rube
burg machine capitalism is is the
machine though driven by surprise so
it's not a machine a machine is defined
by not being surprising and cap and the
thing about surprise is it is his
creativity always comes as a surprise to
us Albert Hirschman said this first but
creativity always comes as a surprise to
us and yes if it didn't we wouldn't need
it and socialism would work but and one
of the big problems in Silicon Valley
they Google philosophy as I as I say
believes that the human mind is somehow
a machine a meat machine as they
describe it and and but a machine by
definition can't produce surprise in the
essence of the human mind is creativity
and unexpected outcomes unexpected
insights imagination imagination allows
you to conceive of contraries of
counterfactuals of new things it's
machine can't do that machine can they
they can imitate it by introducing
randomness to the machine but that's
that's not creative surprise randomness
is subtracting order rather than
actually is subtracting information
subtracting knowledge and the essence of
this thesis is that all wealth is
essentially knowledge and if wealth is
knowledge economic growth is learning
and this is really what I show in
knowledge and power that wealth is
knowledge again economic growth is
learning yeah if you if you consultants
business consultants make of rich living
on the learning curve and they find
learning curves all across the economy
and every sector whether it's producing
eggs or insurance policies or lines of
software code or transistors and on
microchips there's about a twenty to
thirty percent increase in efficiency
with every doubling of total units
produced
so we're sold so learning curves are
ubiquitous across the economy and I
believe that growth itself is the
increase of knowledge which is to find
this learning but there's a crucial
requirement for learning and that is
that the outcome isn't guaranteed if the
outcome is guaranteed learning is really
impossible and growth is impossible and
much of government regulation is
designed to guarantee outcomes and thus
destroy knowledge and [ __ ] economic
growth and that's because the government
is guaranteed thanks y'all it's it's
trying to create it because if you can
guarantee me welfare why would I go and
learn that's that's it and UK and but
but if the government sorta is
guaranteeing that solar energy or
windmills will succeed UK it means that
the solar industry doesn't learn very
much and so all across Massachusetts
where I come from people are putting out
solar panels but they don't attach them
to their houses the solar panels are too
erratic to actually provide electricity
for the homes this is just purely a
response to a government subsidy the
government pays you to creates as the
solar power and then requires the
utility to buy it and that's
guaranteeing outcomes and the result is
no no learning if an actual solar
industry would have to learn how to
produce electricity for houses
distributed power that would be worth
having but instead the government
subsidized solar so they don't have to
if the people who actually tried to
produce real distributed power where
people could tap into the energy coming
from their roof or their solar panels
that would be the learning process and
economic growth would occur but
governments tends to stifle learning by
guaranteeing outcomes thus preventing
the surprises of creative human
creativity fascinating now do you think
that that's important for ma children
being raised into today's world to have
an insatiable appetite for knowledge
that's right they're not epideictic
yosity creativity are the sources of all
wealth and children should be taught
that they shouldn't be taught through
the source of wealth as a government
check yes and that's also the thesis of
Peter Thiel's book zero to one is that
your creativity goes from creating
something into the world is your zero to
one but when you just take a one and
move it across the world that's
globalization that's right yeah yeah
Peter I think that book is a master plan
I think so why oh it's the best business
book I've ever read likewise yeah it's
amazing so good no okay and then I love
though you know wealth is knowledge it's
so important to get young people to care
more about learning now do you think
that that is a responsibility of the
parent to want to in the community and
the teacher before most apparent you
know parents are really critical and I I
i homeschooled my kids for with my wife
and mother and did they throw their kids
as well they I don't my kid my kids only
I only have one grandchild and so far
he's completely homeschooled by Melly
but Gus but
but I didn't do complete homeschooling
it was one or two years yes because I
always felt that junior high was a vast
wasteland there was just nothing
happened in junior high so that you
might as well teach high school stuff
and so yeah we we taught our kids math
and physics and everything and what was
the junior high years and then they've
really could become state cross country
skiing champions and stuff in their high
school years so there should be a time
though that society reflects on the way
that certain people live for example
ones with physical or mental
disabilities and that should be the time
that we give welfare is that kosher I
mean I mean there's a safety net is not
of mistaken I mean it's that we we need
but it's a mistake to to make these two
complete guarantees you know when there
cradle-to-grave safety nets at a certain
point they become noose and they really
stifle growth and knowledge and and
stifle risk-taking and which is critical
to enterprise yeah so so it's it's a
balance but I think it would be great
medical care should be a great
profitable enterprise and engine of
growth yeah and if you could convert
medical care into an engine of growth
rather than a big gigantic super Mel
over and bureaucracy it would be a
tremendous step forward by the way Scott
Gottlieb who used to write a newsletter
for me is now head of the FDA and he's
making a lot of great changes at the FDA
and
so how would a federal Food and Drug
dude yes how would you see different
industries like health care the food
system the education system all these
different tech in many cases systems
that have been around for a very long
time not like today's blockchain and
cryptocurrency trend but let's we'll get
there but as we talk about these food
and healthcare and education systems how
would you see those be maximized to
their fullest potential I mean you could
almost you could abolish the Department
of Agriculture and that with a
tremendous good effect
New Zealand experimented in this way
they and then I think it was the 1980s
their economy which had been the third
most prosperous economy in the world
reached the point where they they were
importing food they couldn't even feed
themselves in New Zealand and they were
dominantly an agricultural society a
Labour government took over of all
things oh I have to say that whoa the
quote or that I learned from you about
the if you you build canoes and then you
go fish and then over maybe a century
there's nobody left that knows how to
make the canoes yeah and you nobody
taught that down the lineage so now all
of a sudden the canoes broken you don't
know how to make canoes anymore and does
that happen with agriculture well
agriculture and and that's what happened
in in New Zealand they forgot how to
feed themselves because the government
took over agriculture 45% of of
agricultural income in New Zealand was
from government programs so Doug was
this great finance minister at the end
took over I'd forgotten the name is name
at the moment but and abolish the whole
government is a zero based budgeting of
all government institution
and particularly zeroed out the
Department of Agriculture from being one
of the dominant bureaucracies in New
Zealand it was reduced to seven people
or something
and the result was that New Zealand
within five years became the most
successful agricultural economy in the
world and with within five years which
is immediate turnaround and they ended
up competing with the Wisconsin dairy
men in dairy products in Wisconsin and
getting sued by the Wisconsin
agricultural people for unfair trading
practices from New Zealand
they had scores of different kinds of
cheeses and different textures of
butters and it was just amazing feat and
all across New Zealand went within a
amazing short time from being a pathetic
laggard in the world economy to being
the most vigorous a country and this and
but this comes down to supporting
innovation when you hold it if you
guarantee everything with all the prices
in agriculture in New Zealand was
guaranteed so there's no learning so
there is no I can have my growth in New
Zealand for three decades so that's the
big thing then is to not impede
innovation to not imagine creativity
especially with regulation oh yeah I
mean I had a company that I helped us
help start and and was on the board that
use carbon nanotubes to filter water and
they could make it a straw that you
could put in a septic tank and drink
pure water out of it and these straws
were used by Special Forces and
gannis tan in Iraq but the EPA rule just
casually one year that carbon nanotubes
resembled asbestos and thus were
probable carcinogen and they banned the
use of carbon nanotubes for water
filtration for consumers in the United
States so this company was just casually
put out of business overnight you know
if the government rules you can't sell
your product yeah unless you are a rich
company you can't compete with that and
that's how regulatory overreach stifles
economic growth I I didn't you know I
always said it but I never really felt
it my gut until the EPA rule but carbon
nanotubes one of the great American
inventions of recent or discoveries of
recent decades was illegal to sell the
customers to consumers it was and I'm
still amazed by it I don't know B there
is no argument yes
carbon nanotubes in some way in size and
shape resembled asbestos but asbestos
shouldn't have been banned either it's
asbestos could have been handled much
better than it than it was you know it
became a complete scandal that actually
destroyed the American chemical industry
36 major chemical companies went
bankrupt as a result of asbestos
litigation and nobody ever proved you
know if you're in a mind sucking in
these fibers if they were the wrong
kinds of asbestos for years you could
get Melo CEO me or whatever the hell
it's called but excuse this but but it
became but but this legal engine was
unleashed by government yeah that that
destroyed the American chemical industry
and nobody could stop it it's still
going on
there's still lawyers and with
billboards across this country
soliciting cases of people who have some
passing relationship with asbestos
asbestos is great
it stops fires fires are bad for the
environment among other things so George
as Californian should know yes of yes
absolutely so maybe now to teach us
about a couple places around the world
that you think do a pretty good job at
the way that they balance innovation
with government regulation well Israel
was the prime example I mean is our why
why Israel all of all of the American
major American companies now have major
of substantial R&D investments in Israel
Intel is really an Israeli company in
disguise ever since it was founded it's
been dependent on Israelis to make major
contributions there they have wafer fab
and design centers that produce many of
their top microprocessor products why
it's so attractive
why is really Israel Israel thrill it's
real
Israel understands that that life is
real you can't if the government screws
up the Israeli economy Israel dies and
so Israel is operates under the gun and
and so they understand that if they
don't develop technologies they'll end
up extinct so Israel Israel has a
reality principle that escapes all of us
who think it's perfectly good to strew
windmills across the country like we're
Don Quixote it's it's really it's really
weird I mean windmills produce no and no
energy to speak up they cost them they
just cluttered the environment and kill
birds and they should be illegal
so so then the fire under Israel's ass
to survive is what really they elect
Netanyahu and and he has had you know
the fat man and and the thin man and he
says you know the thin man was the
private sector and it was bearing the
fat man on his shoulders and the
government yeah and and he he unleashed
the private sector in Israel and the
finance sector the whole thing is Israel
is went through the Great Recession with
no years of down growth there there
there they've been one of the well as in
technology they've been the leading
country in the world certainly for their
size and you and they contribute
crucially to the American economy every
major American a tech company depends
heavily on Israeli ingenuity and
invention you and medical care is yeah I
mean they bail out some of the paralysis
inflicted by Obamacare and what used to
be a completely counterproductive FDA
and you know a lot of the best drug and
inventions come from Israel so no matter
no instruments they you know we're
punishing medical instruments with
special taxes and the Israelis are
generating a whole series of amazing
medical instrument yes so now you say
that in in the innovation is not a
guaranteed increase over time that it
really requires a non to to build
systems that are not that don't foster
complacency but that foster innovation
and creativity over time and I think
this is really well explained with an
example of the teal fellowship and
vitelli uterine because if it wasn't for
that identification at that moment in
time and then the funding of him
would have lost out potentially on that
massive gain of aetherium and what
that's now become in our society
so the fall is a theorem yeah yeah and
so and so that the so that relates into
our next point of conversation about all
of your writing and and research and
conversation with other people in the
industry about what cryptography and
cryptocurrency and blockchain really
means for the world so go ahead and walk
us down well now well I think that the
Internet has reached a kind of Pass you
know I kind of done now it's congealed
into these big pyramids you know sigh
loads of insulated activity of Google
Amazon and and this model doesn't work
it's it's designed to provide for
security you know if each each of these
companies is vain enough to imagine if
they control their whole environment at
least they can provide security within
their domain and if people get hacked
outside it that's not no liability to
them so but if if two nerds that Google
can have their internet and and Mark
Zuckerberg can have his internet and
Jeff Bezos can have his his Internet
then what can't see in ping and China
have his internet and why not the
Iranian mullahs why can't they have
their Internet and this is ultimately
reached a dead end for Google I mean
Google now is finding itself driven out
of China and being harassed all over
Europe it's it's it just is a bad model
the thesis of your next book yum this is
life after Google and we have an
net stack that's perforated and porous
and subject to security flaws at every
level and a porous perforated Internet
stack loves all the money and power to
be sucked up to the top and and leaving
the rest of us to fumble with his
username password combinations and pins
and needles and every other kind of
counterproductive security practice
Google has SWAT teams to solve the
security problem but the but security is
not a video game
security is an architecture and the new
architecture that's been developed from
amazing global rebellion the gaseous new
sclerosis on the internet yes is is the
blockchain revolution the Bitcoin
revolution and crypto and the
cryptographic revolution these are these
are represent an amazing efflorescence
of creativity and and they're they're
just starting really to him to say that
ëthere ahem has such and such flaws so
it's it's a waste of time and bitcoin
has got a counterproductive and Rube
Goldberg machine mining process you know
there are lots of flaws but you can't
deny this just incredible insurgents of
creativity and solving a problem that
government caused government you know
the sec administers ice i POS and they
regulated them to such an extent that
there aren't any anymore in the united
states so now twice as many IPOs in
communist china as we have in the united
states and we were really in a
predicament
and amazing entrepreneurs around the
world solved it at least for the last
couple years with I CEOs which are
initial coin offerings or crypto
offerings you can call them what you
want so there are two times n IPOs in
China now because the SEC called
regulate is obsessed with inside insider
trading yes he sees the essential rule
is you can't invest in anything you know
about Wow what the exit what the SE when
you put it that way it's really what
they're saying they're anti-growth UK
because they've got all these programs
that scrutinize every possible inside
advantage that anyone might have all the
trading has been driven outside so we
have what I call the outsider trading
scandal with where all the computers do
all the trading or or flash boys to the
trading you can't indict a computer and
so SEC is really driven human beings out
of the investment business and
relinquished it to a bunch of machines
and which and you read in in in Barron's
this week that the future is AI
investing and we've just been talking
about what growth is it's knowledge
which is based on information yes which
is surprised and the one thing a machine
can't do is produce surprising
information the machine is the
determinist system and I would also
argue that the way that alphago was
playing and that it was making new moves
in ways that even the professional
players around the world were wondering
whoa we've never seen people make moves
that way before
so there is a little bit of creativity
that's now starting to be seen and I
don't think that's it what they did
alphago
had this you know to go as a determinist
bounded determined bounded arena it's
not like a general intelligence is
created of Korena
it's an arrowy and it's determinist and
if you can play billions of go games a
minute or whatever it was they played
more go games and minutes than all human
beings had played in all history and of
course they exhausted the possibility
space of of go with these multi
gigahertz parallel computers and it has
nothing to do with intelligence or
creativity it's it's it's computer speed
it's and that's it that's what the
actually the the algorithms for machine
learning have hardly improved since the
1950s there isn't a major it gains or
advances almost all the advances are
just microchip Moore's law
supercomputing at gigahertz terahertz of
frequencies you know and and it just
means you can iterate millions of times
faster than humans so of course you can
cover any determined bounded space but
if you turn the world than to determine
bounded spaces you won't have creativity
and and and technological advance and
this is the Google that
counterproductive flaw at the heart of
the Google philosophy they believe that
they can create machines that can
essentially obsolete human beings and
human being should be supported by a
guaranteed annual income while Brennan
page and get on a spaceship with Elon
Musk and explore other planets
so maybe since you since we went there
before we come back to decentralization
and I SEOs since we went there no no you
think that artificial general
intelligence does not pose an
existential threat to humanity it poses
no threat to humans its poses a threat
to humans if it's if the governments or
if government guarantees it or or makes
it the prevailing system what about a
malevolent air creativity stifles rural
creativity I mean what about malevolent
lairs that program the ethics to be
tiller sure well it did their malevolent
you can program new you can program by
all organisms to kill us all you can
program nuclear weapons to kill us all
that that's not a new thing it's always
been possible to could wreak tremendous
devastation across the world with using
advanced technologies but if we stopped
technological advance we'll be overrun
by barbarians
I mean we've of course with you know
it's it's it's not a solution yeah and
so the fact is as long as as in general
good guys and most of us are good guys
can advance the technologies the good
guys will always be ahead oh okay
what but they won't be ahead if the
government tries to ban them or suppress
them and then then of course only the
the malware producers will really have a
free arena to advance soon since we're
all continuing to venture here let's
explore the creed the idea that you
created was in our heads which was the
brain and page and musk take a rocket
out to Mars and other planets meanwhile
all the stupid monkeys stay here on
earth no they think human be there's
nothing for human beings did
it's it's in it you know it's the same
delusion that Marx began with that's
Marxism Marxism believes that and
believed Karl Marx believed that the
first Industrial Revolution the you know
the steam engine electrical power or
always breakthroughs the the first
Industrial Age had solved the problem of
productivity for all time as he put it
and thus the only challenge in the
future would be distribution it was
really you know we'd had to redistribute
existing wealth because known new
productivity was possible and this is
what the Google philosophy is saying
these days that that artificial
intelligence and robotics and
algorithmic biology and all these search
massive new search and suggest
capabilities really exhaust the human
potential and actually leave humans
nothing to do and so most of these guys
are now advocating guaranteed annual
income for everybody that would put most
people to sleep and actually create the
world that they falsely imagine is
enable and that's Marxism it's just a
new form of it it each generation
exaggerate the significance of their own
breakthroughs yeah yeah
so you over time you you're following
the Pinker argument that everything's
slowly rising up and that even though
information technology is kind of
exacerbating the wealth inequality
that's currently had I don't even really
believe that I think what exactly what
creates the inequality was you know this
vast scandal money that I described in
my book the scandal of money tell us a
little about it well you know
you know people don't like the gold
standard or a Bitcoin standard there's
some kind of subtle standard for money
based on on the real scarcities and in
nature and and they so they but they
don't face the total failure of the
global financial system with its which
gave us a tenured recessed Great
Recession or while currency trading rose
to five point one trillion dollars a day
a day of currency trading and a day this
is seventy times as much as all trading
and goods and services in the world
economy it's it's twenty five times all
global GDP put together it's all in on
these currency desks at the big of
eleven big banks mostly and it's
produced this financialization of the of
the economy between the government
issuing money at zero interest rates and
the fast traders in the banks which
don't anymore cultivate economic growth
they're really they're really trading
machines and it's it's just it's and
they have captured as much as forty
percent of the profits in the economy
they've tripled their share of total
economic activity well the whole world
economy went into a terrible slump so
it's clear that finance has become
counterproductive and it's clearer also
that it's been nationalized well you
know they it's sort of a crazy game they
play every few months they find some big
Bank billions of dollars you know it's
been I think a total of three hundred
billion it can't be that it's some it's
some incredible amount of fines
then allocate these bags well at the
same time they're awarded ever more
privileges which and they have partly
because of the SCC and all these other
restrictions on rural investment they
they don't invest anymore as we wander
down banks and currents is so much
currency being traded around the world
every day and the way that banks are now
being more and more concentrated we were
talking about decentralization
what do you see within this space well
this is this is why why I think the
cryptocurrency movement is such a
wonderful providential development for
the world economy it addresses all these
problems at once at the blockchain and
its derivatives and and associated
innovations because they aren't all
exactly block chains or or a new
security architecture for the Internet
kind of a layer eight if you want for
the internet you know there's a seven
layer stack nominally in in Internet
technology and and this is kind of a
layer eight that provides a grounding of
security for the Internet provides
currencies that ultimately I think will
be of made stable currency isn't like
some waters linked to Gold and that's my
I think that ultimately we're gonna find
that thank you that companies like
eagled and digits Dow and these
companies that are actually innovating
in linking the value of crypto
currencies to gold will actually
recreate the gold standard for a digital
age and I think this is a very promising
development because money
is all of central banks of the world
imagine money is a is a magic wand
you know you that can summon economic
growth from the vastly deep and money is
not a magic wand
it's a measuring stick and and what it
ultimately measures is time because time
is what remains scarce when everything
else becomes abundant and and I believe
that yeah tie money is most essentially
time people talk about time is money but
money is really fundamentally time its
it translates this the real scarcity in
all our lives into the economy
if you imagine a barter economy with
nothing but trading goods and services
back and forth through barter you
realize that the time to produce an
incremental unit would determine
essentially its value and it seems to me
Billy what money does is translate the
fundamental scarcities of time into the
economy yes and what Google does in
having all its products free is to try
to escape the constraints of time money
translates time into the economy makes
people have to make grilled choices with
no guarantees which permit learning and
growth Oh
goggle gives all it gives away almost
always products it's kind of reaching
down by past the wallets of its
customers and it's seizing their time
directly with people looking at their
cell phones for 80 hours a week or
something I mean they're amazing figures
for what get at the kind kids spend on
their smartphones and it's it's using
using free apps from Google laughter
time money is
you know and it's liberating it gives
you a bright okay and time is real time
is the most real thing in the world and
we can sense that in subjective
experience through death death is is a
bit well that's that was that's one of
the problems with Bitcoin is time runs
out with Bitcoin Bitcoin has cap and so
it's like real money operates in real
time which extends on into the future
it's a big in any particular in total
well the Bitcoin is capped which means
as it approaches its cap yeah it it
produces all sorts of financial
distortions and they got to change that
or it's or it can't be a measuring stick
unless it can't be a real form of money
it becomes some speculative instrument
but not a real form of money all right
and let's address this is I think this
is an important one to talk about with
you is with the we mentioned this
earlier with Neil's book zero to one it
seems as though a lot of people are
taking whatever is created from that
zero to one and just taking that one and
distributing it across the world
probably most commonly seen today with
the way that China takes the
intellectual property of the United
States and brings it into their country
yeah there's a China is now producing a
lot of intellectual property this is
sorta old news okay and I think it's you
know blame people for our mistakes and
our problems is is not very positive and
yeah and I I you you know I think it's
it's a tragedy that China is is now
going backwards it seems to me even
though they have tremendous capitalists
forces unleashed in China and I believe
capitalism is ultimately more important
than democracy but democracy plays
the crucial role yes because without
democracy the most vicious guys tend to
prevail and this is this is and you hope
that these vicious guys will also have a
good sense of self-interest and
understand that unless they emancipate
their people there they're gonna fail
but but we now have two examples of of
unfortunate leadership in Russia and
China and it's it's really too bad and
the one thing that we can do here is to
inspire young people to innovate to
create that's right and and we with you
know and and not and encourage the
Chinese to be capitalist don't sort of
yeah sound on their exports and I mean
it's it's a lot of that is not positive
I'm not I think Trump and the whole has
been a good president but with the
international trading posture is kind of
self-defeating you know we if the
Chinese want to subsidize their exports
fine we should buy more of them and you
know and make the things we can make and
unleash your creativity and and and
we're doing it I mean they're did Trump
is eliminating lots of regulations and
this is a very positive development he's
you know somebody told me that is now
canceling 18 regulations for everyone he
adds and that you know he promised to do
two for everyone he adds its but he's
way out over performing in this area and
it's very positive for our economy in
our future
all right let's ask you a question from
our book of questions what do you think
the most beautiful thing in the world
you know right
you know woman's body what what do you
what human creativity I think is
exquisite and and to be cherished and
and the aspiration for truth the the
reach toward God are all great human
impulses yeah the understanding that
that universe is great and providential
and and the scientific understanding of
it is a form of worship what is one
thing that you believe to be true that
nobody else believes to be true I think
you know I like to think I agree with
Peter Thiel that that every company you
know pursues a fugitive position of
monopoly you know if bless its if it
doesn't have a monopoly it should go out
of business cuz monopoly means that it's
the only company that does what it does
and and human creativity produces new
things reshape the world and so I think
I certainly think human creativity comes
as a surprise you can't plan it you
can't force it and it's consists of
learning and most people haven't exactly
come to terms with with these
propositions yet
III have wealth is knowledge wealth is
knowledge I don't think some people you
know I
a guy named says are good I had I'll go
and MIT did a very good thing on wealth
is knowledge he says when a great luxury
car crashes against the wall all its
value
appears even though all every molecule
and atom of material remains the car is
knowledge and its value is knowledge and
and and I like that it's you know I
don't know the people George when you
jump into a conversation with somebody
when any of us do the more knowledge we
bring to that conversation the more we
get out of the conversation of somebody
else know yeah and that seems to be one
that I think is very relatable to people
just from their interaction and then we
kind of touched on this earlier but I
know that you don't typically
hypothesize about such things because
they're not right here on our planet but
do you think that advanced civilizations
have birthed into the cosmos and that
they're roaming at colonizing star
systems that kind of a thing no you
think we're alone in the groups we're
alone probably I don't see any there's
no evidence we aren't alone and the idea
that you know in order to escape the
idea that we're alone and thus unique
and thus in some sense of singularity
that we are the singularity scientists
entertained the ridiculous proposition
of infinite multiple parallel universes
there's no not a scintilla of evidence
of multiple universes it's just a kind
of word game played by frustrated
physicists too who can't explain the
uniqueness of the existing universe and
and it's amazing phenomena including the
human mind which they can't even begin
to fathom yet they they just explain it
away they say it's a machine and that's
exactly what it is in this in listen to
the very last thought because you've
addressed this before in your
conversations about being in a
shooter simulation you actually said
that it takes humans away all of that
app sure I thought it takes us away from
the principle of truth of seeking truth
and having a higher maybe god for us
yeah I I mean I really believe this idea
that humans are all part of some
simulation to be a clinical lunacy I
mean there's it's it really is people
who who say this and pretend to believe
it are lunatics and that they may have
they may be geniuses in some fields and
some of them are but it is really a
ludicrous idea you just to laugh at
rather than to think about this has been
such a pleasure wealth is knowledge and
both growth is learning that growth is
learning money is time that's right this
has been an absolute pleasure George
thank you so much welcome thank you so
much for having me this is great I'm
happy you had a good time thank you so
much and hopefully you can stop by our
studio in San Francisco
I hope so a recession in the future my
book comes out I'll water we can promote
yeah together love to do that and we'll
address our well address our viewers at
home quick thank you very much for
tuning in if you guys had a good time
give us a like a comment to subscribe
share the content with other people
let's get this out to the world more of
these thought-provoking conversations
and help us out if you had a good time
it's really important for us to continue
paying for our rent we're all we're all
self funded we're all funded by our
patrons on our patreon account so please
do join us you get great exclusive
benefits for doing so thank you very
much for tuning in and this has been in
partnership with COFA is a congress on
the future of engineering software and
with our partner producer ron vargas
thank you very much for being behind the
camera thank you